[Musique]
la première tournée à l'étranger de leur
classe métropolitaine de montréal
s'achève ici à paris sous les bravos des
vingt-quatre mille spectateurs de la
philharmonie au programme
ales gard ravel debussy berlioz ou cinq
sens des oeuvres chéri de mélomanes
français parfois exigeants c'était très
clair et très élégant comme
interprétation des montres actes le
public est déjà conquis le ravel était
en place était incroyable était
magnifique mais c'est surtout de
l'entente dans un cadre comme ça
le chef yannick nézet-séguin avoue lui
aussi son émotion
[Musique]
au moins d'affirmer ni de paris c'est
une des plus belles salles du monde
c'est certainement une des meilleures
salles récente qui existe c'est vrai que
j'ai visité la philharmonie déjà
quelques reprises à paris je viens à
paris souvent avec mes autres orchestres
ou en tant qu'invité mais avec le rck
est qui m'a vu grandir que j'ai vu
grandir que j'ai aidé à grandir depuis
17 ans c'est sûr que c'est une émotion
incroyable incomparable jose bédié il
s'est tourné a encore renforcé les liens
entre les jeunes chefs et ses musiciens
je pense qu'on s'aime plus maintenant
qui a 17 alors avec cette tournée qui
est quand même de triomphe en triomphe
au delà toutes nos espérances et cet
accueil chaleureux et cette qualité que
les musiciens savent se renouveler mais
reste est heureux d'être ensemble de
faire la musique avec moi bien
enfin que soit sa vie moi je vais rester
avec donc un week end montréal ici à la
philharmonie mais juste en face la
villette propose au public parisien un
mois du québec avec au programme du
théâtre du cirque des expos photos et de
la bd et même des contes pour enfants
jusqu'au 31 décembre
le meilleur de la culture québécoise
sous toutes ses facettes ici gabriel
dejazet radio-canada paris